escape from tarkov had their first alpha
livestream and we've seen a lot of
interest in this game from the shooter
community so here are five things that
we learned about the game number one
objectives as stated in the game's title
your goal is to escape from various
zones but we now know this will not only
involve scavenging but solving puzzles
finding secret rooms avoiding
environmental hazards such as minefields
and contending with both wave-based NPCs
called scavengers and other players in
private military factions such as bear
and you say players are free to engage
in gun fights with anyone but in the
alpha build too much player killing does
result in bad karma which can lead to
negative status effects such as becoming
sick the player controlled private
factions can have as many as ten to
fourteen players there will also be
non-combat NPC's in the game such as
traders number two bullet physics one of
the more interesting parts of the stream
was a demonstration of bullet physics
each bullet has velocity can penetrate
certain types of cover and has a chance
to ricochet ricochets happen when
bullets strike hard objects as they pass
through like cover and even when they
enter bodies it was mentioned that a
round can enter a player and exit in a
random Direction striking another player
the game also includes poorly
manufactured ammo types that can cause
weapons to jam or break checking to see
if a bullet is chambered was shown but
it's unclear if clearing weapon jams
will be a manual process one neat little
touch was how optics are modeled
realistically which should make them
slightly more difficult to use number
three gunfights the combat and escape
from tarkov as in many survival
scavenging games does come down to
finding and conserving ammo however most
of the gunfights we saw had relatively
long time to kill involving body shots
so gunfights should be fairly tense and
come down to lots of maneuvering players
start every life with a pistol and
deaths frequently found shotguns nearby
although a single bullet can kill a
player if they bleed out this was
quickly mitigated by health kits number
four there's a persistent unlock treat
there are five types of skills that a
player can use to build their character
give them an edge and make their post
death starts a little bit easier but
player skill will decline if they don't
play the game for long periods of time
additionally there's a mastering tree
where we saw an elite tier of skills
that did things like reduce the cost of
trading or greatly improve and control
and reduce recoil and number five the
heads-up display well in World escape
from tarkov has a very minimal heads-up
display in fact it's almost non-existent
players will have to click a button to
manually check how many bullets they
have left in the magazine however the
game also has a very intrusive inventory
screen at the time of this alpha any
weapon modding or inventory management
will make players completely vulnerable
as in similar games such as Daisy or
h1z1 my guess is you're going to be
killed very often while in the extensive
weapon modding menu so what do you think
of escape from tarkov so far does it
seem different enough from other
survival shooters to piqued your
interest leave your thoughts in the
comments below and if you saw this on
youtube and you want to see more likes
and subscribes are appreciated for more
coverage of escape from tarkov stay
tuned the game spot calm